[Music]
thanks for being here that was the idea
I know it works really does work you
have been through this as well I'm told
right yeah I got something similar but I
was like hey how about a wig you know
and they were like oh I know what this
is the thing that I'm enraged because
that was painful it is extremely painful
and then it turns out that there are
wigs that you just plop on and you've
got this look in a second yeah this was
like three hours of surgery yeah
basically yeah ten minutes and also it
really exposes how white your scalp is
my scalp is extremely white yes because
and and and I'm white anyway I'm one of
the whitest people alive but then that's
the part of me that never gets Sun yeah
it's been pulled back yeah and there's a
bright light shining out of my head
right now it's making a mockery of the
rest of your faith that's one of the
nicest things anyone's ever said now
that's what you were going for right no
I was going for incredibly sexy I really
thought this would be fantastic yeah but
you you went through this look it was
this for the show
yeah we did it we did an episode where I
was in we did more like braids and they
had to you know do the front part but
right it was um you know I looked good
let's take a look I think we have a
still here and I think you what's that
that's like you know three hours
fantastic
no no you just had your second son I did
Julisa
thank you well six months ago but yes
thank you you know in talk show time you
really yeah it was like I did it in the
dressing room we'll have to check that
out
this was I remember the last that's um
we were talking about your first job was
a home birth did you do that again I did
that I did that again yeah it was way
worse this time it was a disaster it
just lasted like 23 hours this time and
I think I screwed myself because I
thought it's the you know it's your
second baby it's just gonna like come
flying right out of me it didn't and
like like four hours into it what was
progressing really well and my midwife
said cuz if you're at home you got to be
really cautious she was like there's
just something I want to go get checked
out I think you should go to your doctor
my OB which is you know obviously a car
ride away so I had to get in the back of
her Prius which is a wonderfully
environmental car but not great for
labor and the back seat not a labor car
idle aber car at all and not designed
for it I should say that when you buy it
not a labor there was no sticker I
didn't see that they don't mention that
but we go start going through the canyon
to get to my doctor so I'm like having
contractions the backseat taking crazy
turns and it's garbage day and the
garbage truck is just stopping like
every three minutes and I was like I
can't I don't think I can do this
anymore and I leaned forward Rob was in
the front seat and I was like I hope
there's a real problem so we can go to
the hospital and get this thing cut out
of me which was not the plan but you
know I never yeah not a great thing to
say but
I'm judging you with cornrows I disagree
with what you said well move Conan
but everything was fine I had to go home
and have the baby by myself drug-free at
home
23 hours later 23 hours free it was a
nightmare
I mean I love him but it's enough babies
that's it but you know what happens they
say that there's a chemical that's
released eventually in women's brains
that makes them forget the pain of
childbirth I think that they want to do
it again yeah yeah my wife didn't have
that chemical either after the second
kitchen said okay no more right right
cut off neo never to touch me again no
this is gonna turn it around
ship number three on the way America oh
my god
[Laughter]